موجه فراري جماعي للروس في الشهور الماضيه
بسبب العمليه العسكريه الروسيه وخصوصا مع
قرار بوتل للتعبئه وضريبه ذلك فرض ضرائب
اعلى رئيس مجلس النواب الروسي فيتش سلاف
لودر قال ان المجلس يعمل على تشريع ينص
بزياده الضرائب على من غادر البلاد والغاء
امتيازات يحظى بها المواطنون واصفا من ترك
روسيا بالخائنين لوطنهم وفق ما صرح به
المسؤول الروسي على التليجرام
هذا وقد افادت وكاله رويترز نقلا عن وسائل
اعلام روسيه في اوائل اكتوبر بفراري ما
يصل الى 700000 بعد اعلان بوتن التعبئه
الجزئيه لقوات الاحتياط في الجيش سبتمبر
الماضي لاستدعاء ما يصل الى 300000 للقتال
يذكر ان نسبه ضريبه الدخل في روسيا تبلغ
13% وتخصم تلقائيا من الموظفين المحليين
وبحسب هيئه الضرائب الاتحاديه الروسيه يجب
على الروس العاملين بالخارج ولديهم
التزامات ضريبيه دفعها بشكل مستقل رشا
خياطه العربيه